maybe just maybe it's time for a change
with the full report investigative
reporter Fox News contributor Sarah
Carter you know just it this is like
unnecessary preventable death and we're
not even lifting a finger to save these
human lives
yeah Sean what I saw today on the
Streets of Philadelphia what I saw is
not only heartbreaking it's terrifying
as we drove through the streets of
Kensington and through the surrounding
neighborhoods this isn't just one block
this was block after block after block
you could see people shooting up
shooting up uh methamphetamine heroin uh
Fentanyl and the drug that you are
talking about is xylazine it is a
tranquilizer that is used on animals it
is not meant to be used in humans I want
to tell you this Sean just so you could
get a perspective here 95 of the
narcotics here in Philadelphia according
to law enforcement sources I have spoken
to today are coming from the Sinaloa
cartel this fentanyl is coming across
the border those fentanyl precursor
chemicals are coming from none other
than China they are coming to our
streets and they are literally
paralyzing our communities I spoke with
a the drug user today we're keeping her
Anonymous here on the show she was on
the streets I sat with her under an
awning as the rain was pouring on us and
she was telling me about her life and
the horrors of living with this
addiction take a listen to this
you know crocodile have you heard about
it it's made it up here and if you
notice all the wounds out here I mean
there's like everybody's got wounds
amputees more than now I'm out here how
long have you been living on the streets
um right now I've been spurts but right
now I've been about five years I just
lost my husband a year ago to an
infection they've been putting a lot of
this tranquilizer and this what you guys
call on the street crocodile into the
drugs are you scared that
that you may not survive the next hit
you know what's scary is when you kind
of try and clean up or go to the
hospital and then come back out you're
more likely to die like you know what I
mean it's actually trying to get clean
and then coming like trying to just
maintain a a little bit of a feel you
know what I mean that's what's scary is
that like if you do come back you're
more likely to overdose three or four or
five times this out here no I I wish I
was more fearful but no I'm not a lot of
times I hear stories and they say you
know these are zombies
but your people right yeah we are people
we are uh but we're also zombies we're
we're the Knight of Living Dead out here
it's terrible
Sean some of these children on the
street are as young as 15. uh these are
people uh she described herself as a
zombie obviously because of the
addiction I gotta tell you what stunned
me is that there were school buses in
the area dropping kids off after school
there were parents you could see that
they were good parents uh by all means
walking mothers walking with their
children trying to navigate them around
the drug usage around the drug dealers
and I thought to myself as a parent you
know this is Someone's Child this girl
is on the street but she is Someone's
Child these are Americans that are dying
on the streets and I talked to law
enforcement officials that believe that
this is just the tip of the iceberg
eighty percent of the drugs right now
here in Philly are mixed with that
xylazine tranquilizer and they believe
this is going to spread across the
United States
Sean sir I mean what a chilling report
sad report I mean these drugs basically
are people committing suicide they're
killing themselves right before our very
eyes and our children are seeing that as
well uh a well done report but sad to
see people need to wake up we can fix
this
right law enforcement describes it as
chemical warfare in some cases and
that's what we're seeing on our streets
and if covet wasn't bad enough and that
fentanyl is coming from China what is
somebody going to stand up to China it
obviously it won't be Joe because uh his
family Syndicate got a lot of money from
China I doubt he's going to be the one
to to take it on uh Sarah thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else